the November first enrollment window
started for health insurance plans for
2018 and this includes of course
Obamacare exchange plans this includes
private marketplace plans all sorts of
insurance plans you can now enroll for
2018 as of November 1st and I was
pleased to see that here in
Massachusetts health insurance through
so I buy my insurance through the
individual market exchange of the mast
of the state of Massachusetts since I'm
self-employed right I'm in the
individual market I was pleased to see
that my premium is only going up by six
dollars per month in 2018 and I was
prepared for a major increase and I
guess partially because we're in the
more progressive state of Massachusetts
I'm a little bit more insulated from the
deliberate sabotaging of Obamacare and
of the individual market that's been
done by trumps administration and
Republicans in the House and Senate I
really was prepared for something much
worse and I really can't complain with a
$6 a month increase just 72 extra
dollars for the entire year
interestingly though even though we
continue to hear these nightmarish sort
of horror stories from Republicans about
what a disaster Obamacare is despite of
course the fact that it's their attempts
to make it a disaster that are making it
so a record number of people signed up
for Obamacare in the first few days of
the month compared to the same period in
2016
sources close to the Obamacare signup
process told the hill and this was
actually confirmed by a trump
administration official that over
200,000 people selected plans just on
November 1st alone
that's roughly twice the number that did
it on November 1st last year for 2017
plans and traffic on November 1st to
healthcare.gov was up about 1/3 from
750,000 last year up to a million this
year and these numbers are particularly
notable because remember that the Trump
administration has cut funding for
Obamacare related outreach by not 10 20
or 30 percent but by 90 percent
the
Trump administration has also cut grants
to groups that help people enroll in
Obamacare plans
and still we are seeing these huge
numbers now part of it could be that as
part of their sabotage attempts or
sabotage to quote the great William
Shatner enrollment this year is ending
on December 15th so the Republicans in
part of this ongoing effort to make
Obamacare fail they've shortened the
enrollment period which mathematically
would increase the number of people who
sign up per day because you've got fewer
days to sign up but I will remind you
that Standard & Poor's predicted that
enrollment for next year
would be about 1.6 million below 2017
enrollment and President Obama sent out
a shockingly really surprising tweet
about Obamacare on November 1st where
President Obama posted starting today
you can sign up for 2018 health coverage
head on over to healthcare.gov and find
a plan that meets your needs and you
might be wondering well David what
what's so shocking about that tweet
what's shocking and weird is seeing a
president or former president tweet
without including either a personal
attack misspellings or bad grammar or
sir self-serving bragging right just a
simple statement of undeniable fact
which is hey it's November 1st you can
now enroll for 2018 I found that really
stunning in the era of Trump tweeting
kind of like refreshing and a breath of
fresh air in a way I guess I would say
is it possible that the horrible
proposals from Trump and Republicans to
replace Obamacare with terrible things
have actually worked to make more people
realize hey you know this actually isn't
that bad I'm now more interested in
getting one of these plans it could be
an example of the Streisand effect
Streisand effect is named such for
Barbra Streisand where I believe it was
about 14 years ago in 2003 pictures some
kind of paparazzi took pictures of her
huge mansion in Malibu California
and the pictures themselves might not
actually have gotten that much attention
but Barbra Streisand went so bonkers
trying to suppress the pictures that
that became news and it ended up giving
much more attention to the pictures than
otherwise ever would have been paid to
them could be a similar thing right
Trump and Republicans by trying to
repeal Obamacare time after time with
horrible replacement ideas have actually
shown people maybe that those plans
aren't that bad and maybe they're worth
signing up for we'll wait and see what
the final numbers are we will know I
guess in a little more than a month
right on December 16th the video you
just watched was made possible by
support from you please go to
patreon.com slash david pakman show you
can make a pledge of as little as one
dollar per month and every dollar helps
to support the work that we're doing
particularly in light of the YouTube ad
boycott which has been really bad